hey guys how's it going it's Justine and
today I am so excited because all this
week I'm going to be doing a fun cooking
snack video that isn't the theme of
Halloween because it's my favorite
holiday ever so I found this recipe for
s'mores apples s'mores apples hmm so for
these s'mores apples
you're gonna need apples you're gonna
need graham crackers chocolate
marshmallows some butter to put in the
marshmallows and did I mention chocolate
cuz you need your clip so the first
thing that we're gonna do I've already
got some chocolate melting here but
because I love chocolate we're gonna
melt a little bit more chocolate I might
need to give that a nice little mix see
how you're doing in there buddy that's
this is coming along quite nicely sort
of okay we'll let you do your thing in a
saucepan over low heat melt butter
Adamo add marshmallows in the butter as
the melt
oh okay well that's fine I'm not sure
how much butter but I guess I'll cut
this in half looks good to me
okay well that's doing that I'm gonna
stir some of the chocolate and make sure
it's looking good it's actually looking
really really good so while the butter
is melting we need a way to smash these
up butter is melting extremely fast I
feel like I should probably blend these
graham crackers in the cracks bro cracks
the graham crab let's just give it a
little test oh yeah
[Music]
I'm not sure if that's smoke or just
hmmm cracker dust we've got our we've
got our graham cracker mixture so just
dump that in there that looks really
good I'm extremely impressed so this
looks awful we've got our pan that we're
gonna put our apples on here's gonna be
the real test how am I gonna get this
stick inside of the Apple let's just try
it see what happens
ready it's going in yes yes here we go
into the make sure you go oh jeez
oh boy that's not good that's and that's
a mess right there so this is coating
looks good
that looks pretty good it's a little
it's a little yellow from all the butter
because I didn't use a whole stick of
butter and probably half the amount of
marshmallows that I was supposed to so
the ratio of everything is not correct
now let's just put it inside the the
chocolate
oh that looks incredible let's just put
it into the graham cracker mixture
[Music]
I'm cracker looks great
well it's so soft it's like sand and
there's our first one it's a little bit
it's a little not oh boy okay guys this
is our final outcome these are the
s'mores apples I definitely think this
is probably not my best work but I think
clearly this was all I was capable of at
this firm Boyd and I'm super simple
sort of
well thank you guys so much for watching
all this week I'm gonna be having some
fun
spooky snack cooking videos so be sure
to check those out and if you guys try
to recreate any of these recipes I'm a
hundred percent guaranteed that they
will definitely be way better than
anything that I've done here today I'll
see you guys tomorrow
happy Halloween almost Halloween bye
[Music]